könnte zum beispiel sein dass jetzt hier
neben mir in europa zum beispiel ist
also ich weiß nicht ich finde es extrem
toll aber es ist natürlich auf der einen
seite beängstigend wenn man sich mal
vorstellen solche fälle noch besser als
bewusstsein auslöschen
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem wieder meinungs- video von patriot
und mir bei mir hat man jetzt zumindest
man das alte video gesehen vom konto was
ich damals so hatte für meinungs- videos
und wir wollen heute war ein thema
diskutieren was mir in den sinn gekommen
dass beziehungsweise worüber sich petric
auch schon einmal gedanken macht hat und
zwar geht es darum was wäre wenn ihr die
diagnose bekommt ihr habt eine krankheit
und ihr habt quasi nur noch eine woche
zu leben und stärkt danach unverzüglich
egal was ihr macht deswegen erstmal
vertritt hallo ich hoffe ihr kennt mich
noch total verschollen klein erkenntlich
dem vergessen
ja ich hab ja mal letzten tage explizit
über das thema ein bisschen tot nach der
sage ich voll das traurige thema vor
allem so du kannst so ich war zum
schlafen und sohn ich konnte nie so wie
der falter und dann habe ich auch so
überlegte ich immer vorne ist dass du
sowieso krank oder so und dann leg
sowieso nur zwei wochen also mit tattoos
stirn so heftig dass er weg von der
fläche und also früh dann noch so weiß
was ja nicht alles erlebt und vor allem
ja wenn du da so krank bist was nützt
also was willst du denn so machen jetzt
den dienst bei astrid petritz syndrom
und dann mussten zwei wochen leben
daher leiden zu sagen wir mal zwei
wochen ist eigentlich sogar noch besser
sagen
zwei wochen zu leben was ich auf jeden
fall machen würde wäre eigentlich die
träume erfüllen die schon immer machen
wollte
allerdings glaube ich wäre ich sogar
mensch jetzt so nicht sagt so also ich
glaube meine eltern würden echt so alles
daran setzen dass ich die schönsten zwei
wochen meines lebens ihnen die erlebe
die anzahl des todes traurig aber ein
mega traurig werden
das kann man gar nicht beschreiben wie
traurig da angehörige und freunde waren
meine eltern aber ich bin einfach sagen
ich glaube ich wird das nicht so
ausnutzen ich glaube ich wird einfach
mehr zeit mit meiner familie verbringen
da man wird auf jeden fall wirklich auf
diese schule und bildung und auf sowas
würde ich echt total scheiße weil das
bringt mir dann nichts mehr eigentlich
insgesamt investiert die zeit dann
lieber etwas anderes wie dann irgendwie
bei der familie sitzen mit freunden was
unternehmens was als aber ich glaube ich
würde jetzt nicht sagen ja ich mache
jetzt fallschirmspringen und ich mach
jetzt dies und ich will dass da kaufen
und so das kostet 10.000 euro 08 und was
alles weil ich weiß nicht ich finde wenn
man gerade die letzten zwei wochen hat
dann sollte man das zum mit sachen
verbringen halt wünschen von einem
manager natürlich den wunsch hat ja ich
will dich 8 oder so dann okay ich hätte
auch gerne gehabt aber ich glaube ich
wird dann auch in seinen jahren denken
weil wenn ich dann quasi tot bin nach
zwei wochen dann ist es ja quasi alles
verflogen dann ist es ja quasi umsonst
mehr oder weniger deswegen glaube ich
ich würde auf jeden fall mal gern nach
australien reisen oder nochmal nach
london weil da war ich jetzt schon vier
mal in meinem leben das ist einfach eine
geile stadt und sonst würde ich einfach
viel mit meiner familie machen würde ich
jetzt sagen ich weiß nicht wie das ganze
ja also ich hoffe man hört jetzt mein
bruder nicht als fehler gemacht also
doch das hat man in den aktuell
kurze haare die werden schnell trocken
egal ich hoffe das stört nicht
also könnt ja in den kommentar in den
kommentaren so schreiben was wir machen
würde
das ist überhaupt das wichtigste weil
wieder wir machen wollten um eure
meinung quasi ein bisschen dazu fragen
euch so ein bisschen weil japan zu
denken
weil aber die meisten sind ja auch schon
jungen aber die beiden politiker noch
jünger als wir und entsperrungen
bestimmen darüber nie so gedanken
gemacht
viele menschen die durch nichts als eine
krankheit haben dann bescheid bekommen
rorsted muss man zum leben ich stellte
schon vor dasselbe euch die ganze
familie wäre komplett also zweimal
eltern wird das so sein die würden
fortdauern gehen nerven die werden
glaube ich wird die mehr kaputt machen
als ich mich selber als natürlich und
was also ich würde ja wenn es jetzt
kommt so kann es kommt die nachricht kam
thorsten zu zwei wochen zu leben und ich
würde glaube ich natürlich auch schule
ist oder so scheiße habe ich hätte ja
auch videos gesagt also mit der familie
man gleiche schon so ein paar wünsche so
dass ich so sagen kann so bevor ich dann
wenigstens habe ich noch das gemacht
oder sonne
das ist so sinnlos nichts gemacht habe
und so jung gestorben aber wenig wenn
keine ahnung was ich hätte schon gern
also falsche streber schon ist immer
noch mein ziel dass ich auf einmal
machen möchte
weil schon lange gemacht weil es einfach
da oben ja klar weil wenn ich an welcher
stelle sich überhaupt nicht vor allem
ich habe also ich bin so einer der so
einen richtig pech schwarzem humor ich
kann über alles lachen so sowas so
lacht ich mich so behindert vor allem an
sagen die so jahre um lasse darüber dass
voll traurig das ist ja humor wir
meinten nicht so eigentlich war
innerlich wenn man das also mich mal
hinsetzen darüber nicht langsam mal
redet dann wird man auch so innerlich zu
wissen so traurig so weil der herbst ist
ein gott also bei mir ist es so ich
glaube an gott aber ich glaube nicht an
die kirche weil die kirche ist für mich
der größte geldgeile feinden es gibt auf
der kompletten welt in die kirche ist
einfach du willst das ziel ist einfach
nur noch die spitze auf myspace einfach
noch wenn die kirche an der börse geht
weil die ganze scheiße die die
kommerzielle abgezogen habe mit applus
briefen und den ganzen anderen kag und
also ich glaube an gott nicht hoffe mein
gott gibt wann weil wenn es gewesen es
gibt wenn du wenn du weißt dass es gibt
konnte so geschämt sterben das glaubst
du nicht begreifst du titel sterben kann
sondern weil du weißt ja dann irgendwann
stirbt
das ist dann auch wieder die sache so
nach dem tod dass das ist natürlich ein
bisschen offtopic hier von dem anderen
thema aber wir wollen dass er weg ist
jetzt mal parieren und wie so oft wenn
du nur zwei wochen zu leben hast du
jetzt kommen wir denken dank etwas
passiert bin ich sterbe du kannst ja vor
allem die jungen ich hoffe doch so 80
bist zwar hast du da auch schon ein
bisschen angst aber nicht so wie wenn du
1530 unter 50 bist du denkst du ich bin
vermisse naldo da muss man echt immens
aufs alter gucken wenn zum beispiel ein
80-jähriger video gesagt hat sagt ja ich
habe noch zwei wochen dann hat er
natürlich die eltern sind
höchstwahrscheinlich
gestorben und er hat er nur noch kinder
und so was alles und ich glaube nicht 80
wäre und mir gesagt werden würde
ja die ist sterben in zwei wochen wenn
wir die kinder das sagen von mir dann
würde ich sagen ja gut schön dann seid
ihr mich los nach dem motto wenn ich
natürlich jetzt nicht hinten dann das
heißt nicht dass israel wirklich was
komplett anderes ständig alte erst als
haltlos so und viele sagen ja auch so
was tut mir auch selber früher nie so
richtig in den kopf eingedrungen ist so
dann rief jemand stirbt so kannst du ja
das ist tot
also das wäre das noch so viel was
selbstverständlich so ist der tod ist ja
irgendwie jeder stimme als er so nicht
so ja er ist tot aber wo ist darüber
gedanken gemacht das was das heißt tot
zu sein
drachen die so lustig also auch jetzt
allgemein so wegen witzen stil und so
was alles finde ich muss man vorsichtig
mit sein wenn man das unter freunden
macht dann ist das natürlich klar die du
weißt das wissen ja so aber wenn es dann
wirklich mal so weit ist und so was
alles denn dann sieht man dass auch
wieder komplett anders also nochmal auf
diese zwei wochen da zurückzukommen ich
glaube ich würde wirklich einfach zeit
mit meiner familie verbringen zeit mit
meinen freunden verbringen auf jeden
fall dinge tun die schon mal machen
wollte aber nicht auf kosten anderer
leute also nicht zb einem jahr bevor ich
sterbe möchten auch hier eine person
unbedingt foltern oder irgendwie sowas
diesmal aufgeregt also wer so
erfreuliche dinge machen und ich glaube
auch ich würde meinem umkreis der dann
natürlich extrem traurig sein wird würde
ich einfach sagen die sonst normal
verhalten gegen von mir und nicht
traurig sein weil ich will auch nicht
sterben ja ja der welt weist das alle um
mich und trauern das will ich ihnen die
auch nicht das ist halt willst also dass
diese wochen also ganz normale wochen
sind so wenigstens etwas es halt nicht
so alles so dass hat will das thema
überhaupt immer ist jeden tag der
traurigkeit dass er stirbt und dann das
was genießt noch die zwei wochen so dass
sie ja alle alle traurig keiner kann
sich so freuen so das wahr was machen
kann und das meer das ist vielleicht
sogar geschenke von den typen oder der
braucht doch irgendwie
spenden oder etwa nicht ja es gibt so
eine seite im internet da ist so ein typ
der wirklich nur noch drei jahre zu
leben hat der krankheit die er ist
glaube ich alles und das ist halt das
also alles eine krankheit dass zum
beispiel dann richtig zeitgesetz jemand
ein rechter arm hier zum beispiel wenn
du hier wirst oder so irgendwann wird
das ganz langsam die bewegung diese
ganzen nerven die jetzt quasi für die
muskelbewegung zuständig sind
frieren quasi ein und der die familie
kordt seinen rechten arm schon quasi
blockiert sage ich mal unter linker arm
ist auch gerade schon dabei warum hat er
so wenig zu leben was hat das denn
damals zu tun mit seiner lebenszeit dass
seine arme nicht funktionieren weil das
ist die krankheit dass er nach und nach
immer weniger körperteile bewegen kann
und sei dann im rollstuhl und dann
entweder mehr oder weniger das
ästhetische qualvoller tod gibt ich weiß
nicht ich habe mit den artikel nicht
komplett gewesen eine therapie oder
sowas wie könnt euch das einfach drunter
schreiben mit ihr euch einfach mal die
story durchliest ich will jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie sagen ja spendet für
mirko das alles weil ich finde es gibt
so viele andere leute auf der welt die
hilfe vertragen könnten und wenn man da
jetzt einer partie dürfte natürlich
super gerne von euch schon wenn ich
lesen den mirko hier hervorheben wohl
das halt wirklich komplett sehr sehr
viele leute sind die wirklich
irgendwelche schicksalsschläge haben das
schreckliche ist ja auch wirklich dass
auch leute die ihr zum beispiel weiß
nicht an gott glauben und ganz viel
arbeiten und sich der gesellschaft
unterordnen und handeln für die
gesellschaft so was alles dass die dann
immens heftige schicksalsschläge haben
als zum beispiel eine person die fünf
menschen umgebracht hat und einfach kein
schicksalsschlag in seinem leben
ja wir erfahren vielleicht passiert ja
was nach dem tod kann weiß man ja nicht
alles ist ja so hat jetzt auch wieder so
eine sache so nach der freiheit will
muss man sich über diese menschen die
leben alle also auch wenn du stirbst an
ist denn dein körper nicht aber
irgendwie hat das schon was also das
könnte da wie gesagt für die hoffnung
stirbt immer zuletzt
das sind ja schon so so krass zu leben
ist ja schon so wenn man sich das
überlegt so wie kannst du überhaupt
leben das schon krass aber was ich nicht
auch noch sagen wollte versprecher ich
würde jetzt nicht zwingen zu spinnen
aber also ich mach das schon gerne also
wenn schon kinder gibt's ein bisschen
mehr bettler und sonne
dass ich dann so wenigstens mal feiern
gehe und dann so auf dem weg dahin
da sehe ich immer so ein bettler dass
ich den weg sowie in 50 cent oder euro
oder gebe weil da hast du ja nicht so
einen unterstützen unterstützung durch
den staat wie hier weil da hat es im
pappkarton und da muss darauf schlafen
sondern drehte halten keiner krumm haben
und wenn du wenn du jetzt mit mehr staat
ankommen kann man hier natürlich in
deutschland aussagen dass leute die auf
der straße leben und sich wirklich
ergibt asylheim und obdachlosenheime und
arbeitslosen gesellschaften liga für die
arbeit haben und wir haben auch hartz 4
und arbeitslosengeld 2 halt wo die leute
natürlich die sich bemühen
doch zweimal im monat muss man sich um
eine stelle ein schreiben wenn ihr die
dann keinen job bekommen dass sie dann
halt hat vier bekommen eine wohnung und
keine ahnung was allianz das ist halt
schon mega gut geregelt in deutschland
allerdings wo du gerade angesprochen
hast nach dem tod ist es halt wirklich
auch noch mal so eine sache wenn man
natürlich weiß nach den zwei wochen ist
alles aus was ich mir nicht vorstellen
kann weil man man kann man sagt immer so
leicht ja dann ist man halt und ist man
da aber ich mag
wenn man ganz ganz lange darüber
nachdenken habe schneller geht muss man
so denken wie ist es wenn man nicht mehr
da ist wie es ist wenn man den körper
ist wie ist es viel einfacher wenn man
einfach nur da ist wenn man einfach
quasi gar nicht mehr da ist wenn man
überhaupt nicht mehr denken kann wenn
man nichts mehr machen
wie ist es wenn man komplett weg ist ich
weiß nicht wie das versteht aber dann
sagen natürlich alle ja dann ist man
ihnen worum schwarzen und schwebt darum
und sonne
das ist einfach so ich weiß nicht ich
kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen dass
man wirklich komplett weg ist das ist ja
eigentlich vorstellen vor allem so 200
jahre weg und dann würdest du wieso
reden kann aktionen dass jan entsteht
das werk von luxus irgendwelche
öffentlich jetzt wurde aber für die
ewigkeit
also ich könnte mir vorstellen ist das
vielleicht so was so geht woher kommt
denn dein jetziges bewusstsein machst du
jetzt hast woher kommt das
und das kann ja schon sein dass da ein
bewusster machst du hast später wieder
irgendwie in einen anderen körper oder
in die anderen volk kommt und aber halt
nicht mehr davon weiß so dass irgendwie
sind man das wird schon irgendwie so
bewusst sein woher kommt das was man
sich so mega erklären kann finde ich
deshalb habe ich ja auch immer so zu so
hoffnung nach dem verursacher also heute
vom leben nicht so erklären kann also
keine ahnung was männer ja klar du
könntest woher kommt das alles ist was
alles also was ich zum beispiel ich hab
so ein paar theorien was halt nach dem
tod kommt werden dass alles in theologie
also dass länge über gott und den tod
und das alles in religion gemacht was
wobei religion halte ich mein
lieblingsfach ist wenn man einfach zu
diskutieren jahres an meiner
lieblingsfächer jedenfalls haben wir
halt über das leben nach dem tod
gesprochen da gab's halt das war so ein
diskussions ohne wo man verschiedene
einwände machen kann reinwerfen kann und
man man man kann auf keine antwort
kommen weils halt niemanden gibt der das
irgendwie festlegen kann
bla bla bla deswegen also was ich
wirklich meine vorstellung ist wie ich
denke wie sein könnte ist dass man
wirklich als ich sag mal geist wieder
zurück kommt auf die welt das man halt
überall durchgehen kann und das paradies
für die lebenden menschen allerdings
dass man halt wirklich nur die lebenden
menschen dient und nicht die ganzen
anderen geister die die herumtollen
diese ganze habe leute das wäre schon
voller luxus idee schon gestorben sind
also man ist halt quasi daran der welt
aber man ist könnte zum beispiel sein
dass jetzt hier neben mir dann mein
uropa zum beispiel ist also ich weiß
nicht ich finde es extrem toll aber es
ist natürlich auf der einen seite
beängstigend wenn man sich das mal
vorstellen solche verlassen oder noch
besser als bewusstsein auslöschung ja
bewusstseins aus welchen ist das
allerletzte finde ich das ist wir können
das nicht sagen aber spielt das wäre
traurig wenn das neue jahre
ich denke da muss ich ihnen was sein ich
denke du weißt ja nichts mehr das heißt
da kann es doch nicht so [ __ ] nein mein
bewusster das leck das weiß ja nicht
mehr
das ist ja weg weil ist diese nahtod
erfahrungen findet ihr schon tot ist
dann auch wieder wenden wenn du
überlegen willst was nach dem tod kommt
das was wir jetzt sagen so dass man den
geist geht oder sowas ist es ja von der
materie bzw medizin medizinische
überhaupt nicht zu erklären sondern ist
dann halt quasi sowie wie die welt quasi
entstanden ist durch gott dass er das
alles geformt hat in sieben tagen dass
der siebte tag dann ruhetag ist am
sonntag allerdings gibt's natürlich
diese medizinische bzw
menschliche auffassung das ist alles
durch den urknall entstanden ist
lebensform sich weiterentwickelt haben
ich glaube die darwins theorie darwins
theorie später noch mit ein erbe als
davor dann wenn man wirklich jetzt sagt
sie ja nach dem tod wird man geist oder
nach dem tod bewusst sein weg und so
bewusster weg ist medizin mäßig dass man
halt wie sieg wirklich verwest war sie
mit der zeit und das dass man halt
wieder zurück kommt auf die erde dass es
leben nach dem tod
so etwas ist mehr
auf gott bezogen deswegen schreibt meine
kommentare wenn ihr wollt es natürlich
sehr privat ob er an gott glaubt und was
eure erfahrungen so mit
schicksalsschlägen sind natürlich jetzt
natürlich sein dass ein zuschauer
irgendwie guten freund verloren hat bei
einem autounfall oder so was braucht ihr
natürlich nicht schreiben da will ich
jetzt noch gar nicht offen aus er halte
die wollen können dass er uns echt mal
mit teils recht interessant vor allem
sagen auch sehr wichtig ich wollte etwas
wichtiges sagen und zwar beim letzten
kommentare auch so und es ist mir das
später eingefallen und zwar hat er erst
denken dann reden die ich hab mir mal
nachgedacht aber ist mein handy genommen
und dann war der gedankensprung ja schon
weg aber genau vor dem urknall
da war nix ist schon soviel einfach nix
das ist gar nicht so nah quasi einen
klumpen masse also klar nur so vor allem
was andere sagen genau was hat denn weil
ich meine warum lieben wir dann was
macht das denn für einen sinn dass wir
leben ja wenn ihr nach dem sinn fragte
bei allem nach den sinnfragen war
warum gibt es zum beispiel eine
regierende macht also der staat oder die
medien werden die mittlerweile auch
schon gut aber da muss man jetzt so viel
aussuchen und so was alles ist wahr dass
es wird das mit den rahmen sprengen wenn
man über den sinn des lebens nachdenken
hat das leben keinen sinn für uns das
ist einfach eigentlich eigentlich gibt
es keinen sinn
wir sind einfach das lebende des lebens
der sinn das ist einfach so ich würde
sagen david bender das video mal was
würdet ihr machen schreibt uns drei
sachen liegen darin
erstens was würdet ihr machen wir noch
zwei wochen zu leben hätten zweitens
abwägen welche schicksalsschläge in
ihrem leben schon mitgemacht und wollte
darüber reden wir wollen natürlich nicht
jetzt sagen schreibt uns eure kommentare
sondern wenn ihr wollt können uns das
echt schreiben und drittens
und die sache mit gott glaubt ihr an
gott oder nicht ist auch eine private
sache
und was haltet ihr von unserer meinung
also das schreibt uns dass meine
kommentare was halten sie allgemein von
diesem format zu unsere meinung wo wir
eventuell ein paar witzige themen reden
über irgendwas was in teilzeit
beschäftigt und geht dann daumen hoch
wenn ihr mehr davon wollte und schaut
auch bei patrick vorbei nämlich seinem
letzten wort gegeben
danke dass sie mich eingeladen hass und
amüsant und wie gesagt schreibt den
kommentaren eure meinung wenn ihr
darüber offen sprechen konnte nicht
immer sagen ich bin auch draußen rein